Même si nous essayions de tout bien faire,
nous recevions tout de même un flot de vidéos de protestation
et d'emails d'indignation et même un paquet
que nous avons dû faire scanner par la sécurité,
mais nous devons nous souvenir
que les gens prêtent énormément d'attention
à ce genre de choses,
car ces produits, ce travail,
comptent vraiment pour eux.
Nous savons désormais
que nous devons prêter attention aux détails, être conscients
de la manière d'utiliser l'information dans notre processus de conception,
et nous devons introduire le changement avec beaucoup de précautions.
Ces choses sont très utiles. Des expérimentations essentielles
pour la conception de projets à grande échelle.
Mais elles ne veulent rien dire
si vous ne comprenez pas quelque chose de bien plus fondamental.
Vous devez comprendre pour qui vous concevez le produit.
Quand vous vous fixez pour but de concevoir un design
pour l'ensemble de la race humaine et que vous vous engagez
dans ce projet en toute bonne foi,
vous finissez par foncer dans le mur et éclater la bulle où vous vivez.
A San Francisco, nous sommes
un peu contrariés dans une zone sans réseau
car nous ne pouvons pas utiliser nos téléphones portables
pour trouver le chemin du nouveau café branché.
Mais qu'en serait-il si vous deviez conduire pendant quatre heures
pour recharger votre téléphone portable faute de source d'électricité fiable ?
Qu'en serait-il s'il n'y avait plus d'accès aux bibliothèques publiques ?
Et si votre pays n'avait plus de presse libre ?
Qu'est-ce que ces produits signifieraient pour vous ?
Voilà ce que Google, YouTube et Facebook
représentent pour le reste du monde et c'est ce qu'ils représentent
pour les cinq milliards de gens qui se connectent sur Internet.
Concevoir des projets pour des portables bas de gamme
n'est pas un travail glamour, mais si vous voulez concevoir
des projets pour le monde entier,
vous devez penser vos projets pour les gens, et non pour vous.
Comment garder cela en tête ?
Nous essayons de sortir de notre bulle pour regarder, écouter
et comprendre les gens pour qui nous travaillons.
Nous utilisons nos produits dans d'autres langues que l'anglais
pour s'assurer qu'ils fonctionnent aussi bien.
Nous essayons d'utiliser l'un de ces téléphones
de temps en temps pour rester en contact avec leur réalité.
Qu'est-ce que ça signifie de concevoir des projets à l'échelle mondiale ?
Cela signifie un travail difficile et parfois exaspérant
afin de perfectionner les produits.
Trouver l'audace et l'humilité pour y parvenir peut être épuisant,
et l'humilité requise,
est un peu pénible pour l'égo.
Parce que ces produits changent perpétuellement,
tout ce que j'ai conçu au cours de ma carrière
a globalement disparu,
et tout ce que je concevrai
finira par disparaître.
Mais voilà ce qui reste :
le frisson sans fin de faire partie
de quelque chose qui est tellement grand,
que vous pouvez difficilement le saisir dans sa globalité et la promesse
qu'il pourrait bien changer le monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)